welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar cannabis as an
anti-cancer treatment the scientific and
human evidence it is presented by Justin
candor research & development
coordinator at the oil plant my name is
Julie O'Rourke and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box on the far left of your
screen and type your questions into the
drop-down box our speaker will respond
to your questions via email following
the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're experiencing
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits now about
further ado please join me in welcoming
Justin candor I will now turn the
presentation over to him hello thank you
so much for having me it's an honor to
present here and I'm excited to get
started and sharing this very important
information so jumping right in how does
cannabis fight cancer most of the
research with cells and animals has
focused on the two primary cannabinoids
in cannabis tetrahydrocannabinol and
cannabidiol the studies have identified
four primary ways that these and other
cannabinoids can fight cancer the most
direct method is the induction of
apoptosis or programmed cell death this
is where the cannabinoids bind to either
the
cb1 or cb2 receptors on the surface of
cancer cells and trigger this program
cell death where the cells break down
into these little a pop tonic bodies for
neat digestion in addition the receptor
activation can also inhibit the PO
reformation of cancer cells stop the
formation of blood vessels to solid
tumors which is a key step in their
growth and prevent the metastasis of
cancer cells to other organs which is
also a key step in the progression of
cancer most of the evidence
demonstrating these effects has been
conducted pre clinically with cell lines
derived from humans and sometimes
animals as well as animal studies where
the cancers are in plants and animals
and the tumors are allowed to grow the
next level is anecdotal evidence which
is which most of the human evidence is
found in these are human stories that
have been self-reported or reported in
the media where people who have used
high doses of cannabis extracts are
achieving remission while most of it is
anecdotal there actually are a couple
case reports that are formally published
in medical journals that point to these
anti-cancer effects as well finally we
desperately need clinical trials
conceived of controlled and double
blinded to further demonstrate these
effects and what we do need more there
is one great trial that I'll talk about
at the end which backs up everything
else the preclinical evidence is quite
remarkable in itself dozens of studies
have shown how both THC and CBD can kill
numerous types of human cancer cells and
shrink tumors and animals so this is a
pretty complete but not all influence of
list of the various forms of cancers
that have been shown to respond in these
preclinical studies so this includes
glioma brain tumors various forms of
breast cancer leukemia thyroid cancer
multiple myeloma it really is remarkable
just how many forms of cancer have been
shown in these sites to respond and I'm
going to go over just a couple of these
studies
show how they're gone so first this is
THC against liver cancer specifically
the epitope cellular carcinoma horn so
the researchers found that THC induced
programmed cell death in two different
cell lines and that mice who were
implanted with these cancer cells and
allowed to have the tumors grown have
lower tumor growth when administered
with cannabinoids so as you can see with
the controls the tumors are much bigger
and the cannabinoid treatment group in
this case the researchers both used the
natural plant-based phyto cannabinoid
THC as well as a thin synthetic
cannabinoid known as jwh or one of the
jwh family members which is a synthetic
lab made cannabinoid that activates
cannabinoid receptors and researchers do
this to identify the mechanisms by which
cannabinoids work as THC has targets
beyond the cannabinoid receptors but
this helps show that those receptors are
indeed critical to this anti-cancer
effect CBD is also potent it's been
shown to kill two types of glioma cells
an administration of half a milligram
additive CBD two mice reduced tumor
growth pretty significantly and while
both THC and CBD have been shown to work
on their own in these studies the video
Power Appeals appears to occur when
they're combined so this is a study that
looked at the synergy between THC and
CBD for a form of glioma brain tumors
and the black bar on the very left is
the untreated cancer cell so at that
point the cell viability is at 100% it's
completely fine with the THC and the CBD
alone the red and green arrows there's a
significant decrease in the viability
but when they're combined the effect is
much greater than either of them alone
or additively showing that they work
synergistically in a greater than
additive matter to inhibit this cancer
while THC and CBD have certainly gotten
the most focus all the major phyto
cannabinoids have been shown to possess
anti-cancer properties including the raw
unheated cannabinoids like THC a this is
a really great chart that it just
provides a good overview of how the
different cannabinoids are shown to
affect eight different types of cancer
cells so going along you have breast
cancer brain prostate thyroid colorectal
breast leukemia and gastric cancers and
it looks a little complicated it's not
too bad
every number in these boxes represents
the ic50 value which is the
concentration required to inhibit pleura
for a ssin of a cancer cell by 50%
compared with in control so in this case
with the mcf7 breast cancer cells
it took 4.2 micromoles which is about
4.5 milligrams of THC to inhibit this
form of cancer by 50% going below you
can see in this case the THC a and CBD
were more potent as it required less of
these compounds to achieve that 50%
inhibition so it's basically the point
of this is just to show how the various
vital cannabinoids and the actual whole
plant extracts which are at the bottom
the THC and CBD rich extracts work
against multiple forms of cancer there
are also a couple of unique anti-cancer
effects beyond those four that are
pretty well characterized one of the
most difficult parts of treating
treating gliomas and certain other
tumors as the presence of stem cells and
these tumors that are resistant to
chemotherapy and radiation one study
that found that CBD could stimulate the
differentiation of these Kaleo must
stand like cells into more developed
cells and prime them to respond to
conventional treatments and the research
didn't define that the CVD synergize for
the chemotherapeutic agent karma Steen
to increase apoptosis in these cells
where the agent alone was not effective
pointing to the very powerful synergy
that can exist between conventional and
cannabinoid therapy immunotherapy has
also been getting a lot of attention and
there's some evidence that both CBD and
to some extent THC can help the immune
system fight cancer
a study tested both cannabinoids on lung
cancer cells and found an increase of
protein called I cam 1 which is
intercellular adhesion molecule one on
the lung cancer cells it kind of does
what it sounds like it helps the cells
and here to special anti tumor white
blood cells that allows them to be
destroyed and the researchers found that
this cannabinoid induced increase in
that protein was responsible for
enhanced tumor cell elimination by the
immune system this is all pretty good
information but there are a lot of
natural compounds that are capable of
many of these things and what really
sets cannabinoids apart is the
anti-cancer effects of our own
endocannabinoids system and no
cannabinoids are the cannabinoid
compounds produced in our own bodies
that act in similar ways to the phyto
cannabinoids produced in the cannabis
plant and these compounds primarily an
and amide have been shown to induce
apoptosis through similar mechanisms as
THC and CBD this is a few of the cancer
cell lines have been shown to respond to
an and amide and even indirectly
increasing the levels of an and amide
and the other primary and new
cannabinoid to eg is linked to the
prevention of colon cancer in animal
studies so when you inhibit the
degradation you indirectly raise those
levels and that has benefits with the
strong science is not surprising that
there's a lot of great human evidence to
back this up and I'm just going to go
over a little
but here but there's there so much more
out there one of the most well known
case studies was published in November
2013 and described a 14 year old female
with terminal acute lymphoblastic
leukemia who had not responded to
chemotherapy and radiation
she used cannabis oil as a last resort
and doctors tracked the leukemic cancer
cell count as she was using the cannabis
and as the as the chart shows there was
a dramatic decrease in the leukemic
blast cell count while using the
cannabinoids while this chart happens to
say hemp oil this was made back in a
time when that often referred to THC
rich cannabis oil now it's far more
associated with tease but CBD rich oil
but this does indeed refer to what's he
see Brett's treatment unfortunately this
particular patient did pass away as the
result of the gastrointestinal
perforation from the PV previous
conventional treatment however the
doctors remark how the therapy that had
an increase in the patient's vitality no
toxic side effects and hadn't been able
to control the blast all accounts so if
she's been able to get the cannabis
Souter potentially with the chemotherapy
things may have worked out better a more
recent article focused on a 44 year old
man who was using vaporized and topical
cannabis for a squamous cell carcinoma
and ochite he was initially just using
vaporized cannabis to deal with the pain
of this cancer but as it continued to
grow the vaporization became impractical
and he began applying a cannabis infused
sunflower oil on it which was of a
relatively low potency for topical
cancer treatment however despite this
low potency there was a reversal of the
tumors growth after the topical had
started as you can see from the tumor
size column it was growing quite rapidly
while the man was only vaporizing can
however once you start applying the
topical oil it actually began to shrink
which is extremely rare with the
fast-growing cancer like that and really
only explainable by the potential
anti-tumor properties
unfortunately giving that he was using a
load a low concentration oil and
apparently not ingesting very much
internally he passed away from apparent
metastasis however the case reporters
author dr. Vincent Maia remarked how
after a few weeks of the topical
application the malignant wound had
started to to regress and this outcome
suggested the topical medical cannabis
may promote antineoplastic activity as
per the findings of Casanova at all that
study he's referring to is one that used
actually synthetic cannabinoids
including one of the jwh family members
that the earlier lever cancer study used
to show how cannabinoid receptor
activation leads to the death of skin
tumor cells
most of the human evidence has been
reported in the media or by by people
themselves through YouTube or Facebook
and and it truly is remarkable how many
stories there are and I'll just go over
a couple one of the one recent story
focused on a woman named D mani who had
been diagnosed with triple negative
breast cancer in March 2017
she made the personal decision to try
and teach here which cannabis oil as the
sole therapy which she obtained through
a local supplier she was taking one drop
in a capsule every night before bed and
by August 2017 doctors determined she
was cancer-free and as this scan results
show it was quite a remarkable effect
and just to briefly go through a few
other human cases first we have Lynn
Cameron who was diagnosed with a brain
tumor and given just six to 18 months to
live even with conventional treatment
she combined the oil with that treatment
and achieved full remission within six
MRI scans and is still doing well to
this day
Augusta Fleming had been diagnosed with
lymphoma and underwent the full course
of chemotherapy which proved effective
in her case as a last resort she moved
to Colorado to take large doses of THC
rich cannabis oil and within three
months a Stan showed no evidence of
disease follow-up a year later also
showed continued inactivity finally we
have Gary Hill who was diagnosed with
lung cancer and given six to twelve
months to live at his age he decided he
didn't want to potentially endure
chemotherapy and try to legal form of
CVD oil within two months a CT scan
revealed a near total resolution of his
left lower long mask and most of his
lymph nodes were normal size and as of
the publishing of that article he was in
remission and what really gives even
more credence to all of these cases is
the fact that there is post ebu
controlled evidence of an anti-cancer or
placebo a placebo controlled trial
showing anti-cancer evidence in humans
this was published in February 2017 by
GW Pharmaceuticals this was the results
from their phase two placebo control
trial using a THC CBD mixed their
sativex plants specifically for a
glioblastoma the 21 patients were given
either the THC CBD blend and
chemotherapy or the placebo and
chemotherapy while the study itself did
not specify the exact dose a physician
from another conference who looked into
it determined that it was likely only a
maximum of sixty two milligrams per day
total cannabinoids that these patients
were getting which is very low for
potentially achieving an anti-cancer
effect making these results even more
impressive the median survival for the
cannabinoid group was about six months
longer than the placebo group and for a
cancer likely to blastoma were even with
treatment the two-year survival was only
thirty percent a six-month extension is
very significant and as the principal
investigator professor susan short
remarked indeed the pharmacology of CBD
and THC appears distinct from the
existing
education and may offer a unique and
possibly synergistic option for future
Glee on the treatment so overall the
evidence is quite strong for the use of
cannabis for cancer both
endocannabinoids and phyto cannabinoids
have been shown to affect many types of
cancer cells through similar mechanisms
primarily the activation of the cb1 and
cb2 receptors however other receptors
often come into play some of these
effects have been observed in humans
through the case studies and I do want
to as quickly discuss Apple app see
because I this really bolsters the
chance that the preclinical evidence for
cancer would also translate to humans oh
it's very well known now that CBD is and
it's actually completely proven through
GWS placebo-controlled files that CBD
can reduce seizures and patients with
dravet syndrome
however the preclinical evidence focuses
on CBD for a largely for chemical driven
seizures which are far less complex and
the genetically driven seizures that
patients are experiencing with Turvey
with trouve syndrome and so if the
preclinical evidence is translating so
well the humans for that it does at
least make it somewhat more likely that
other radical preclinical results like
for cancer won't translate to humans and
I do have a book at free cannabis cancer
4.com that has over 100 human cases and
several animal cases dogs and cats along
with extensive analysis of the
preclinical evidence and when all of
this is examined together it's very
clear that cannabis can absolutely have
an anti-cancer effect in humans and
certain animals however we desperately
need more research to characterize the
extent and limits of efficacy there's no
doubt that many people don't respond to
high doses of cannabis for their cancers
for one reason or another for example if
the tumors don't express high levels of
cannabinoid receptors that's why we
desperately need more research and
anybody who uses cannabis
for cancer so it absolutely had medical
oversight and keep close track of the
cancers progress to see if it's working
nonetheless while we have so much more
left to learn what the current evidence
more than justifies the access of
cannabis for patients who want it and as
time goes on further research will help
us get even better results thank you so
much and enjoy the rest of the
conference Thank You Justin for that
informative presentation I'd also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that this
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through June 28 2019 as a final
reminder our speaker will follow up with
any questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we will see you next time bye